The world we experience
isn't just given to us.
The brain is actively generating
our experienced worlds
every moment of every day.
If I'm sitting on the beach,
and I open my eyes,
I suddenly see
before me the sea, the waves,
I can feel the breeze on my face,
I can hear the seagulls
in the distance.
It seems like there's this
objective world out there,
and it's just pouring itself
into my mind through the senses.
Yet, I know that's not
what's going on.
The signals that arrive
at our eyes and our ears,
the light waves that hit our retinas,
the pressure waves
that come into our eardrums,
they don't come with labels on them,
like "I'm from a seagull",
or "I'm from the sea",
or "I'm blue".
They're just ambiguous signals.
The brain has to make sense
of all these sensory signals
and figure out where they came from
and what they mean.
That's the process of perception.
So perception isn't just a reading
out of the world around us,
it's always a creative act
of interpretation
in which the brain is utilising its
knowledge about the way the world is,
to make its best guess
of what causes the sensory signals,
and that - that's what we
consciously perceive.
So the brain has what you might call
prior knowledge,
about the structure of the world
and about what's out there,
that allows it to interpret
the sensory signals that come in.
And sometimes this prior knowledge
is built deep into the structure
of our brain,
and it's knowledge that
we're not aware of having.
For example, that light tends always
to come from above.
And that means that,
when we look at shadows,
our brain is using that knowledge
so that we interpret what
shadows mean in a particular way.
It's not so much
"I'll believe it when I see it",
but if your brain believes it,
then you will see it.
Perhaps the real world
just isn't something
that's useful for us to see.
We are evolved
biological organisms,
our brains have limited capacities,
we see the world as it's most useful
to us in order to survive.
Colour is a very, very familiar
feature of our visual experience
that gives our lives texture
and beauty and meaning.
Does colour exist in the world?
Well not really, no. There are just
light waves of different wavelengths,
and out of those wavelengths,
the brain generates an infinite
variety of different colours.
And why does it do this? Well,
it allows the brain to keep track
of objects as lighting
conditions change.
As the artist Cezanne once said,
"colour is the place where
the brain and the universe meet".
This process is going to be a little
bit different for each of us,
we're all going to experience
our own interpretations
of even the same sensory data.
And this brings up this idea
of inner perceptual diversity.
Now we're all familiar
with the idea of external diversity.
We all recognise that
we're different heights,
different skin colours,
different shapes,
and we're less familiar
with the idea of inner diversity.
One reason is that
you can't see my experience.
If you look at the blue sky,
the blue that you experience
might not be the same
as the blue that I experience,
even though
we'll both call it blue.
There's one example
of perceptual diversity,
which became very well known
a few years ago.
It was this photo of a dress that
half the world saw as blue and black,
and half the world saw
as white and gold.
These bits are blue,
and these bits are black.
Definitely.
The people that saw it
as blue and black
were so convinced that
what they saw was the way it is
that they couldn't understand
how other people
could see it differently.
And the same went for the people
that saw it to be white and gold.
Don't you see it?
Part of the reason was that it was
a very badly exposed photograph.
So it was very ambiguous,
and the colour that it seemed to be
depended on the assumptions
your brain was making
about the ambient surrounding light.
Okay, if we see that
so differently,
what about the rest
of our experience?
How can we assume that in other cases
we're experiencing the same thing?
The answer is we probably aren't.
It can almost be used as a lever
to help people better communicate
with each other.
Because if you can demonstrate
that even something
as apparently straightforward
as opening your eyes
and looking at a photograph
can lead to such different
beliefs about what's going on,
then we can begin to recognise
that other people
may see things differently,
believe things differently.
A lot of challenges in communicating
with each other
might be rooted in the fact
that our literal experience
of the same world is different.
It's not that these things
don't exist - they exist -
but the way
in which they exist for me
is completely dependent
on my brain.
We do all experience a shared world,
a shared reality,
but our way of experiencing it
is individual. It's unique.
And it's very precious
because of that.